all right so i want to go over a couple
of these stories which have now become
all too common where some anti-vax
person some cova denier some
anti-faucist whatever
um ends up getting sick and dying of
coronavirus and one of these stories i
know fahren did while i was gone but i
want to give my take on it and i i think
there's there's quite a bit to say
uh these are not like fun happy stories
they're not funny stories
for me it's not i mean listen you guys
know i don't take pleasure in the death
of of folks who
just fell for for bad information
but we can't ignore the fact that
especially when they change their mind
on the vaccine once they get sick and
people hear that
it can be a cautionary tale and it may
actually have some impact in getting
getting more people to go ahead and get
vaccinated so let's start with the first
one
this is a story of h scott appley
a texas republican official
who mocked
the covid pandemic
five days before
dying of the virus
okay
h scott aptly
the daily beast writes a republican
official from texas who regularly
espoused anti-vaccine anti-mask views
online
has died from covet 19
five days after posting a meme
on facebook
questionating i'm sorry questionating
questioning the wisdom of getting
inoculated against covid
dickinson city council member and state
republican executive committee member h
scott appley 45 years old not 65 plus
not 75 85 the way many republicans like
to say 45 year old h scott appley
died in a local hospital around 3 a.m
wednesday morning
according to a gofundme page
set up to help his family with expenses
now i'm going to get to that in a moment
as well
he was admitted to the facility in
galveston on sunday with pneumonia-like
symptoms hooked up to a ventilator as
his condition worsened his wife was also
infected um
texas republican party chairman matt
rinaldi said please join me in lifting
the aptly family up in prayer
see
instead of praying now
what about vaccinating before
is is that crazy is that a crazy
reaction to have now the prayer
of going on to say we will miss scott
deeply but find comfort
in knowing he's at peace in the arms of
our savior
you find comfort in that
what about the fact that he could have
been vaccinated and would have been
very unlikely to see this happen
what about that part the opposite of
comfort is what that should be
the announcement did not mention that
aptly's death was coveted related
aptly is a staunch conservative and
devout christian
but based on his social media activity
aptly didn't believe covid was going to
affect him or his family
in may aptly posted an invitation for a
mask burning being held at a bar in
cincinnati commenting i wish i lived in
the area a couple weeks earlier he
posted a news article about giveaways
and incentives meant to encourage people
to get vaccinated writing disgusting
aptly also railed against so-called
vaccine passports which restrict
high-risk activities such as indoor
dining to the fully vaccinated
recently he suggested mass mandates in
germany were akin to nazism
and when former baltimore health
commissioner leanna wen celebrated good
news about the pfizer vaccine efficacy
a seemingly outraged aptly called her an
absolute enemy
of a free people you know you can go
it's all the same stuff in facebook
posts aptly wrote if businesses start
allowing customers and employees go mask
free only with voluntarily providing
their vaccination record presumably not
a hipaa misspelled violation
wouldn't that basically involuntary it's
we can't even understand a word this guy
was writing
what a mess
so listen what what are the takeaways
here
i'm not happy this guy died but if his
death serves to get some anti-vaxxers
vaccinated
it will not be totally in vain although
it is a senseless death
which almost certainly not a hundred
percent but almost certainly could have
been prevented with a vaccine so
takeaway number one
we have something the vaccine
which makes you really unlikely to get
super sick and die of covet now
there's data coming out about
breakthrough deaths right
uh we're learning that we're probably
all heading towards third doses we'll
talk about that tomorrow big
announcement expected probably today
we're learning that uh efficacy wanes
over time
but it's still a very powerful tool for
making you unlikely to be hospitalized
and die
that's takeaway number one
um now some people still will die right
like with flu
with colds sometimes
in a con you know in a planet of seven
billion people
things that don't normally cause a
problem statistically very small number
but still a percentage
will cause a problem and people will die
but most won't when they are vaccinated
it's the best tool we have in choosing
not to take advantage of it is absurd
now the gofundme page i mentioned that
they have a gofundme
they talk about personal responsibility
they choose not to get vaccinated
they still expect to be taken care of at
the hospital
and then they or their families beg for
money for health care
which almost certainly is not money they
would need
because
they didn't get vaccinated had they
gotten vaccinated they probably wouldn't
need that money that is not personal
responsibility that is not personal
responsibility and that's another aspect
earlier in the show i talked about
you know the stated principles for lots
of these people
they're not deeply held beliefs they're
just what they think they can say now to
get what they want out of society or out
of a government or out of people in
their lives and the principles are
abandoned as soon as it's no longer
convenient for them let's now talk about
another one of these stories sadly